je vous rappelle que quatre jours plus
tard serge pomerleau denis lefebvre et
yves denis sont toujours au large donc
accusé de trafic de drogue et de meurtre
d'ailleurs leur signalement a été
transmis aujourd'hui à interpol ils font
donc l'objet d'un avis de recherche
international depuis aujourd'hui dans un
instant je reçois la ministre de la
sécurité publique lise thériault mais
d'abord car une bassine nous dit qu'en
prison ce n'est pas un problème du tout
pour les détenus de communes au pied de
communiquer pardon avec l'extérieur des
téléphones intelligents il y en a des
centaines dans les prisons du québec
même s'ils sont interdits la preuve un
des trois évadés du centre correctionnel
de québec denis lefebvre commenter les
photos de son fils pendant qu'il était
en prison
daniel benson qui travaillent avec les
détenus explique dans les centres
correctionnels du québec
les mesures de sécurité sont beaucoup
moins sévères que dans les institutions
fédérales
c'est sûr qu'au niveau fédéral ça arrive
qu'ils vont changer de téléphone celle
là mais c'est très très jaune reste des
événements très isolé au provincial de
ce que j'entends des établissements
provinciaux
il y en a beaucoup plus selon le
syndicat des agents de la paix en
services correctionnels les cellulaires
sont problématiques pour presque tous
les établissements de détention s'il y a
un cellulaire il y a donc accès internet
les détenus peuvent donc communiquer
facilement avec l'extérieur
il ya beaucoup plus d'entrées et de
sorties dans les prisons provinciales et
il ya moins de mesures de sécurité je
vous dirai à l'entrée des établissements
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de roulement
vous savez car qu'on rende un
pénitencier fédéral il ya nécessairement
portiques de détection de métal sont son
niveau nous fouiller avec un important
des acteurs de métallier des chiens
renifleurs
il ya de la sécurité qui est bien en
place c'est lors de leur entrée en
prison que les prévenus se voit
attribuer une cote de sécurité qui
varient entre est ce un peu dangereux
jusqu'à s5 très dangereux jean lortie a
été sous-ministre associé et directeur
général des services correctionnels
entre 2007 et 2010 il affirme que c'est
un agent de classement qui accorde une
cote de sécurité aux détenus une cote
attribuée sur la base des informations
transmises par les policiers
90% je dirai au moins de l'information
vient des cars de police qu'ils ont
arrêté pourquoi ils détiennent
quels sont les accusations qui vont
apporter
est-ce que l'individu fait partie d'un
groupe criminalisé à ce sont ces
informations lors qu'ils vont servir à
faire un classement
plusieurs observateurs se demandent
toujours pourquoi la cote de sécurité de
denis lefebvre yves denis et serge
pomerleau avait été réduite alors que
les policiers de la sûreté du québec
avait déjà informé les autorités
carcérales que les trois fugitifs
planifiait de s'évader par hélicoptère
ici car une bastien radio canada
montréal la ministre lise thériault est
avec nous bonsoir madame thériault ou
danse à recevoir un matériau donc ce
qu'on comprend c'est que pour vous vous
êtes ministre la sécurité publique
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de confusion
dans la trame dans l'histoire depuis
samedi lé il ya des choses que vous ne
comprenez pas vous même je dirais pas
tellement de la confusion comme des
contradictions dans la transmission
d'informations qui
sont mises à la disposition de mon
cabinet évidemment vous n'êtes pas sans
savoir que dans cette évasion lors faut
comprendre que la sûreté du québec
elle était impliquée au dos aussi de par
la nature même les centres
correctionnels
le ministère de la justice et la
sécurité publique qui mon ministère donc
moins comme béni je dois demander je
pose des questions je m'attends à boire
de la bonne information
je m'attends à voir de l'information
complète je ne m'attends surtout pas
avoir d'informations contradictoires
qu'en dit qu'il fait beau dehors je pars
pour écrire l'information que
l'information est contradictoire donnez
moi un exemple précis la dent dossier
bages et il ya des informations que je
peux pas vous donner parce que je ne
veux pas biaisé ce qui se passe devant
nous j'ai déclenché une commission pas
une commission une enquête publique
monsieur roy parce que les informations
ou ne sont pas au rendez vous et ça
prend l'information sont veut prendre
des décisions et si je veux répondre à
vos questions
si je veux rassurer la population je
veux répondre aux questions de la
population
j'ai besoin d'informations je vous pose
une question quelle enquête
administrative
je pose une question très simple oui à
partir du moment où la sûreté du québec
alerte les autorités carcérales qui a un
complot pour évasion chasse ses sorties
nos journalistes selon d'autres
journalistes l'ont aussi une information
qui est béton à partir du moment où là
est ce qu a l'air de la prison qu'est ce
qui est arrivé d'après vous on a 1000
soit côté comme information pourquoi on
n'a pas tenu compte de cette information
là c'est ça fait ça fait partie de ce
cas seulement qui aient la main sur wow
cinq top je peux ajouter également que
vous savez que procès qui se déroule
présentement à québec où les trois
fugitifs sont impliqués il ya des
requins qui ont été présentés à un juge
qui a rendu des ordonnances
tout est frappée d'un interdit de
non-publication et y est évident que
c'est lié donc j'ai de l'information que
je ne peux malheureusement pour vous
donner
parce que sinon je risque de faire
avorter un procès et c'est parce que je
veux croyez moi donc d'accord mais je
leur posais la question différemment
vous êtes au courant comme nous donc
forcément que la sûreté du québec savez
que c'est trois galas voulait partir
oui bon je lis les journaux et je
regarde aussi les bulletins de nouvelles
à ce port est ce que il est exact que
cette information-là a été envoyée à la
prison je n'ose pas vous répondre là
dessus parce que je ne veux pas aller
contre l'interdît de non-publication non
plus fait que vous me permettrez de ne
pas confirmer ou d'infirmer que les
formations qui pourraient donner comme
résultat de faire avorter rêvassait mais
le premier ministre n'était pas de très
bonne humeur et vous non plus j'imagine
donc ça veut dire que à cette question
là est ce que les autorités carcérales
ont pris au sérieux la menace
j'imagine que j'avais des réponses
contradictoires pour moi - de dire ça je
nous avons des réponses contradictoires
sur beaucoup de questions que nous
posons donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle les trois entités qui sont sous
ma responsabilité c'est à dire la sûreté
du québec les centres de détention
le ministère de la sécurité publique et
joint assault le ministère de la justice
puisqu'il était appelée fera partie de
ce sur quoi
l'enquêteur va se pencher ce qu'il faut
comprendre le monsieur roy c'est que il
ya les événements qu'on a devant nous
avec les éleveurs les deux les trois
évasions
mais faut regarder l'ensemble de
l'oeuvre qu'est ce qui a précédé cette
évasion laquelle on ôte et les prémices
les conditions il faut remonter jusqu'à
1 au mois de mars 2013
à partir du moment où en mars 2013
jo jo une tentative d'évasion on a pris
les bandits tant mieux
faut se poser la question qu'est ce
qu'on a fait parce qu'il faut éviter ça
et ça c'est tout y est donc l'enquêté
administrative va se pencher à partir de
la première évasion qu'est ce qui était
demandé qu'est ce que t'es fait qu'on
dilapide effet combien de temps cette
enquête là vous donnez combien de temps
pour qu'elle soit bouclée d'ici vendredi
vous aurez le nom de la personne qui
mènera l'enquète vous aurez le mandat
exact et vous aurez et
dans l'échéancier et mon souhait le plus
cher c'est que l'information soit connue
qu'elle soit sur la place publique pour
rassurer la population et donner des
réponses à vos questions monsieur roy en
terminant à madame laminé c'est ce que
vous excluez que quelqu'un dans la
prison a été achetée carrément par ces
trois fugitifs
moi je pense que là que l'enquêteur au
dossier va vraiment faire la lumière sur
toutes ces questions là parce que c'est
ça qu'il ya plusieurs intervenants qui
sont interpellés puis ça permet vraiment
de pouvoir faire la lumière sur ce qui
s'est passé ça va faire partie des
questions qui seront étudiées c'était
bien combien de prison actuellement son
sont possiblement sujettes à ce genre
d'évasion là au québec
je peux vous donner l'information il ya
présentement au québec 18 centres de
détention qui sont sous notre
responsabilité nous avons demandé à voir
13 de nos centres de détention qui
pourrait être couvert par un interdit d'
espaces aériens si vous voulez ceux qui
parce que dans ces centres de détention
lors il y à des personnes qui pourraient
tenter de s'évader parce qu'il faut
comprendre que on a des détenus des
prévenus il ya des gens qui ne veulent
pas assister à la prochaine mais qu'ils
ont les moyens de se payer une évasion
spectaculaire comme ont eu donc on a
évalué le risque c'est dans les choses
qu'on a fait on a demandé à avoir un
espace de protection une protection des
espaces aériens pour ses centres de
détention lors d'une manière graduelle
et temporaire pour pouvoir faire les
aménagements qui s'imposent pour éviter
que ça se représente une troisième fois
je ne peux malheureusement vous donner
les noms des centres mon fur et à mesure
qu'ils seront couverts par l'espace
protégé et l'italie comprendre quels
sont les centres de diversion parce que
je voudrais passer ou les clés pour
pouvoir leur envol il serait surprenant
qu'un troisième hélicoptère douceur
tandis du moment où on les sait et c'est
ça qu'il faut se poser comme question
qu'est-ce qu'on a pris comme l'action
sur les relais ray dans les centres de
détention pour que ça se reproduise plus
madame la ministre touche sans règlement
ils sont toujours au large
malheureusement voilà il n'y a pas de
piste sa lâcheté des enquêtes policières
puis vous comprendrez que les bandits et
des coteaux si les nouvelles donc c'est
la formation qu'on va garder pour nous
merci alain thériault a lâché 3 voix